[Music]
i think
for years
you've been avoiding earth
i have called for your help plenty of
other times and you've been pretty
content to let those calls go straight
to voicemail
yeah well
this is different
how much you know about your security
detail
what do you mean how much do i know
about him
fury
we're going to be very careful now
you're in no shape for this fight that
lies before us
[Applause]
[Music]
this is just the beginning
this is my war
alone
and i'm the last person standing between
them
and what they really want
and what is that
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the one that you saved
you are as its father
a clan
of two
[Music]
but you have removed your helmet
then you are a mandalorian
no more
your cult
fractured our people
where were you then
did you think your dad was the only
mandalorian
all right kid
hang on
you ready for an adventure
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
out of the sea
[Music]
wish i could be
part of that world
[Music]
spies
saboteurs
assassins
we've all done terrible things on behalf
of the rebellion
cassian ander
don't matter what you tell me or tell
yourself
you'll ultimately die fighting these
bastards
wouldn't you rather give it all at once
to something real
[Music]
we've chosen a side
we're fighting against the dark
there is an organized rebel effort drill
down and get a hunt started
you realize what you set in motion
people will suffer
time has come to force their hand
at what cost everything
every day we wait
they get stronger
let's take them by surprise
for the greater good call it what you
have
let's call it
war
people are standing up
they're afraid right now they're afraid
star wars and or three episode premiere
streaming september 21st
this holds a clue to a treasure of
utmost importance
i thought about destroying it a million
times
look at these symbols
in order to prevent it falling into the
wrong hands
the daughters of the plume serpent were
here
[Music]
so we're talking like an honest to god
treasure map
yeah
where'd you get that necklace it was my
dad's
he died when i was a baby
what is it
that's the symbol on your necklace i
know
what if i told you everything you know
about your dad is a lie
alec leads to an important treasure
and searching for it is dangerous i know
it is
this is cooler than any room on any
episode of cribs i've ever seen ben
franklin glasses oh my god
i want that relic
everything i thought i knew about my dad
my whole family for that matter is
a crazy riddle that can only be solved
by finding this treasure
trust no one
[Music]
what's uh what's your clue i would love
to love to help out
i banish thee from salem
forever
[Music]
they were right to fear thee
magic has a way of uniting
happy 16th birthday child
i have a gift from my favorite customers
legend has it it's on the 16th birthday
that a witch gets her power
gilbert where did you get that candle we
have to get out of here the witches will
be here any second
the book is alive he woke up
if we intend to live past sunrise we
have to steal their souls
maniac obsessed with getting revenge on
salem so
very bad for salem
we should get some salt why so it tastes
better when they eat us
spread out
[Music]
that's not six feet under
stop i am a good zombie
[Music]
you think you know what is real
and what isn't
what is light
what is dark
now
forget all you know
come with me
[Music]
we're looking for the sorcerer willow
i was told that once long ago you
defeated the forces of evil you remind
me of your mother
my dear friend i thought i could prevent
all this
i was wrong
my brother was abducted the world needs
you again it needs your magic
follow me
[Music]
we must go
beyond the edge of our world
into the unknown
i need your help just like old times
running horses
happy to see
our it enemy is still out there
rallying the forces of evil
and the only thing standing in its path
is us
i'm going to enjoy this if you're
thinking i'm thinking
i doubt that very much take him to my
tent make sure he's tied up i don't know
see that kind of sounds like on the same
page
when i was a kid i used to play at being
a sorcerer
visiting strange worlds fighting
monsters
never thought i'd actually really do it
what the hell is that
trolls i'm so miffed
same as last time
with my friends
[Music]
everywhere there is life
but
you must face
death
[Music]
honor it
do not fear it
jedi
ahsoka is jedi
[Music]
the best way i can protect you
is to teach you how to protect
yourself master dooku i want to bring
peace and order to the galaxy
master stop
it is the only way you will truly have
victory my opponent
again
again
[Music]
i've been warning them about the coming
darkness
let's hope all that training pays off
and who might you be
[Music]
look
i didn't want to be a half blood
being a half blood is dangerous
it's scary
most of the time it gets you killed
if you think you might be one of us
my advice is
turn away while you still can
believe whatever lie your mom or dad
told you about your birth
try to live a normal life
[Music]
because once you know what you are
you'll sense it too
[Music]
and they'll come for you
don't say i didn't warn you
[Music]
i know the change can be scary but it
can also be exciting
if i learned anything from meeting
princess on a billboard is that
sometimes you just have to take a leap
let's start our new life
pretty soon this whole place will feel
like home you'll see
it's all part of the adventure that's
not an adventure that's a landfill a
land filled with adventure
oh it's what they call a fixer-upper yes
once your peasants have dug out the moat
and added a turret and a balcony from
which you can sing i see it now
okay
melvina monroe i would have sold you
this house but i deal in slightly more
upscale homes
in the andalasia the hardest part of
life is finding your happily ever after
this world's very different
if this world is not to your liking then
you must change it i wish
[Music]
i wish
jumping jelly sticks wait how am i
talking
i wish for a fairy tale life and it's
all gone terribly wrong or terribly
right
at the last stroke
nothing will be as it was before
[Music]
oh giselle what have you done
that's a wicked wicked good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this halloween
you can't escape the shock
the terror of
werewolf by night
tonight
it is every hunter for themselves
good luck
i'll be
rotting for you
but one of you is a monster
masquerading as one of our own
i can't wait to find out what breed of
evil you are
[Music]
[Applause]
please don't do
is coming for you
werewolf by night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
strength is beauty beauty is strength
what makes you beautiful she-hulk by
titania
this is the person who legally
outmaneuvered you
yeah
why didn't you trademark your own
pseudonym why would i uh
did doctor strange have to trademark his
name did thor you chose two examples of
people who use their real names
i'm still jennifer walters she-hulk is
just a thing that happened to me you
said you didn't like the name she helped
i don't i do admit though there are
parts of it that i enjoy
the amazing hair
no hangover
being able to walk home at night without
being afraid
[Music]
you put on your green suit put on my
green tape yeah jolly green yourself i
don't know what you call it hulking out
okay good whatever
trouble's gonna find you
weird unexpected trouble
[Music]
i'll be right back
life would be so much easier if i was
just jet i think you're in a unique
position to do some real good jen
walters can use the law to help people
when society fails she-hulk can help
people when the law fails
this guy's really kind of doing it for
me
[Music]
oh
did you get a ticket for texting just
say you were texting 9-1-1 they can't
prosecute that isn't what this is and
that's not true
[Music]
it's time
let's go
now streaming lightning mcqueen and
mater are
you picked the last three stops
mater mcqueen
[Music]
during the last few years we ventured
into a lot of different fields i only
hope that we never lose sight of one
thing it was all started by a mouse
simple circle oh gosh
mickey is
a thing we all share there aren't many
of those around
wow
i can't believe that the summer is not
over already please wait a minute before
anyone's ordering us around hey girls
well that was fun while it lasted
see that girl this girl is gonna make my
team better according to tmz she just
bit naomi osaka
i don't play with losers and i never
lose life's a little more exciting than
d2 isn't it
at the end of each day i want you all to
look in the mirror and ask yourself did
i do my very best today everything you
guys do in this gym and out affects all
of us where we're going is anything but
no more
always
there's points here
just a little bit so does this mean our
school's co-ed like for real do you have
any idea how complicated this is about
to get
heads up
these boys have been here for five
minutes already they think they can just
walk all over us we'll give you
permission to use my court miss thomas
said we could use it i have to share my
gym it's not your gym it's my gym and
yes you're gonna have to share it
when the boys arrive they're the
priority they came into our school it's
not fair
you know what i love is when he gets so
upset that a little bang pops out and he
starts stuttering
i just want to prove that i'm still on
the top of my game oh you're teeing me
up huh there's your story i'll give you
a reason to be proud of me that's all
dad you've gone from being a villain to
being a joke i will never give in to
fear you don't always have to be the
strong one can inspire anyone i know
you're gonna find the words
what you are as a person is more
important than what you are as a player
scared right terrified
i did not expect us to end up here
tonight either oh
you seem nice and cool
i'm also kind of scary
things will never be the same
wow thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
take a good look at each other that's
who we play for that's what we can count
why are boys just the worst
thing they just continue to rip my heart
out
[Music]
attention everyone
[Applause]
santa has an announcement to make
[Music]
for the good of christmas
for the good of my family
i santa claus
have decided to retire
we have a grief counselor right
you're interviewing becomes santa claus
yes can't wait to rub this in brady's
face all i do is give us your best ho ho
ho okay here we go
ho ho omaha
you see that i called a little audible
there anyhow thanks so much i sing by
the way
no brady can say
[Music]
[Music]
hey we're here
[Music]
i've been waiting for this all my life
i'm so excited about the princess party
why i always got to be the court jester
because you're too cheap to buy a new
costume
aren't you gonna change yeah
the game
i want you to massage my feet
[Music]
[Music]
that's right
right where i left them
[Music]
you